what attracted you to this role and to
this screenplay really first it was the
idea of playing a character like that in
this world I always grew up I grew up
served with that my mother's Italian my
so I grew up in that put that side of
the family my grandmother wasn't just an
incredible cook in my family we talked
about what we were going to eat what we
just ate what we were putting in the
freezer for Tamar to eat hmm so it was
always you know there was it was the
epicenter of our household everything
took place in the kitchen all the drama
took place in the kitchen all the
hilarity yeah and then I worked at a
restaurant so I was a kid I was fifteen
so I just always loved the world and
then the idea of playing a character
who's at that level which I had no
experience with which was mind-blowing
actually doing a service at Ramsay in
hospital row with Claire Smyth was an
incredible she's a female head chef
there's a three Michelin star and she's
just incredible so yet the world was the
one the other thing was the cast Harvey
Weinstein was talking when he talked to
me about the movie talked about
assembling an international cast and
talked about Omar and Ricardo and Emma
Thompson and I just sounded really
exciting and then Steve and I wrote an
incredible script that's been around a
long time and then when John Wells came
aboard well he's sort of you know
unparalleled and what he's done it all
just sort of came together and shooting
in London the trick was but was in
between sniper and Elephant Man so that
was so I was like trying to lose weight
for the Elephant Man's out of you could
see in the movies I could see ten pounds
lighter and that seemed that he was the
scene before one of the things I first
noticed not that far into burnt was the
dialogue of this movie is razor razor
sharp now like in working and developing
the film and and developed my character
working with Siena again after American
sniper did you stick to the script where
you allow to sort of go off a little bit
and just get into the character a little
more the script was that was the basis
for everything there are a couple of
scenes where we were able to excuse me
um improvise a little I mean when you're
working in the kitchen I mean a lot of
that was just creating I mean Steve
nitro
the scenes in the kitchen as a sort of
engine and then you know it's gonna
Marcus wearing for example was there
everyday just about and and he he was
invaluable I would ask him to do the
scene before and just watch him just all
the little things that a chef would do I
mean taking the back of a spoon you're
tasting the way you would play the meal
and the way you how you would talk to
people and how you would talk about
presenting a dish out there all those
things came from Marcus which I think
Steve knew was gonna happen once we go
and said well you know the the dynamic
of a of a chef they're so like like
boxers they're like musicians they're
artists and they're just it's such an
unusual character to play like I said
I've worked in kitchen so I was aware of
the high pressure and and the fact that
I would be horrible at it I remember
being I was a waiter and during college
and just the idea of like what they need
ice cream and then that neither the
pizza here and and you know four things
I was like losing my mind the idea of
being a head chef at the pass which is
basically the the threshold before the
food is being prepared onto its way in
out to service you know having to be
able to coordinate all of the timing for
the fish to arrive and the meat to
arrive in the garnish it's just ink you
know and have everything be able to
overlook everything and also trust
everybody that's behind you
is it level of pressure entity first of
all no you know when you cook the people
come over you prove like four people
it's like it's like World War three in
the in the kitchen you imagine cooking
for 6070 people I mean I can't even
imagine like it's like ways you have to
be like yeah it'd be crazy but then to
do it at this level I mean I was blown
away when I was at that this woman
Claire smart that I was talking about to
see how they how their kitchens are run
and it's an educated audience this day
and age and we were very aware of that
you know with boiling point which was
this documentary that the BBC made on
Gordon Ramsay when he was going after
his third star that was sort of the
origin of all this now you know kitchen
kitchen shows and and but the audience
is very aware of what goes on behind the
scenes so we had to make sure that it
was as real as we can make it
working with Sienna again because you
spent a lot of time apart in American
sniper you spend a much more
time together in this movie so how was
it to work with her again
well I begged her to do the movie yeah I
mean I knew that it you know we worked
so well together and I just think she's
on mind as an actor she's incredible and
I thought she did an incredible job in
this film I mean the carrot I really do
she was great and I also knew that there
was gonna there really needs to be a
level of trust I mean the scene where he
where he berates his Brigade you know
and that scene between that he has money
pushes her I mean that was that was
something that we kind of created on the
day and we never would have been able to
do that if we didn't have the trust that
we had because that was a really
difficult scene and that people did feel
I think scared so so but but yeah I mean
that when you have that sort of
foundation of what we had just gone
through and also the the fun of playing
completely different characters was also
fun but you went from playing a
real-life character to a fictional
character yeah so in playing a fictional
character do you feel like that gives
you a little bit more freedom to create
that character even though it's written
and give working with the director
you're working with the writer do you
feel like a little less pressure to sort
of develop the character on your own
versus when you were playing American
sniper it's just a different kind of
pressure but you still want to make a
create a compelling story and I did feel
pressure in terms of being believed
because you are playing someone that is
at a certain level in in his field and
all of the other cooks that are in the
kitchen are actual chefs in round London
all the extras that are cooking because
we are actually cooking food and there
are no sort of at hand doubles or cook
doubles we're all doing it
and Marcus Waring was it behind the
monitor all the time so I did feel that
pressure to make it believable because
he had no problem telling me that it
wasn't which I loved because you want to
get it right so there was that pressure
but it's just a different kind of
creative process mostly in the research
you know when you're playing a real
character as opposed to a character that
lives in this on the page but I had the
wonderful access to Marco Pierre White
and Gordon Ramsay and Marcus Waring and
three really incredible guys and and and
that was really fun and I tried to like
just little didn't actually wasn't
conscious but little certain things like
more
appear white when every talks he's
always like this Coria and it's simple
ingredients and I remember like it went
in the Burger King scene he does this
he's like talking to see yet and he does
that I'm like oh that's the market for
what when you were you grew up you work
the restaurant so did I by the way I
think we are like have a similar
backgrounds here but do you feel like
when you're at home after making the
smoothie do you go I think I'm gonna
make a really good dinner now like you
feel like you're like a better cook
after making this well I definitely
learned how how how much I'm not a cook
doing the movie for sure but I
definitely learned a tremendous amount
about plating food I mean that's really
what those guys do more than anything
they're the plating the food and that
that was incredible just to watch Marcus
wear and create a dish was was and then
to be able to do it myself within the
confines of the story was it was fun and
I definitely do I think since that have
gone a little crazy with the plating of
food even today now that I think about
it